let's speak to the chancellor rishi
sunay who joins us once again
on the programme chancellor uh really
good to see you this morning and
no england shirt on i'm gobsmacked but
but i have to say very pleased to see
you
were you up late last night
i i i was i am at least wearing a red
tie
neil so that's my my attempt at wearing
the england shirt during my uh my work
day
but yeah i know i was up late absolutely
overjoyed tense at times
obviously but fantastic night great for
the country
first time in my lifetime we'll be in a
final of a major competition so can't
wait
and and as regards that final i mean is
it coming home do you think you can do
it
i you know i do i feel good i mean i i
was euro 96 was my
football tournament coming of age i
remember it passionately
it was an amazing summer it feels like
that all over again wembley last night
what i mean what a spectacle to have
everyone cheering the way they were we
haven't seen that in so long
it felt absolutely amazing it was tense
at times no point pretending otherwise
and uh maybe a bit of a soft penalty but
we got there in the end
and i just watching sterling run past
everybody time after time it was amazing
i am overjoyed
and you know i can't wait so just going
to point out to viewers that it was you
that said it was a soft penalty and and
not me but but
just just a reflection though chancellor
on what this might mean to the country
we've all had 16 months of a pretty
torrid time
even getting to a final is a remarkable
achievement by gareth southgate and the
boys
i i i think it's an amazing moment for
the country
and we've obviously had a it's been a
tough year for lots of uh different
reasons
but to have this to look forward to at
the end of it is
absolutely fantastic and it reminds us
of what life was like before we had to
deal with coronavirus
actually you know to have people at
football match to have our sharing and
an experience as a country together
something
that brings us together you could see
that on the fans last night you can see
that across the country households
everywhere
and i know everyone's gonna be looking
forward to sunday with an extra 45
minutes in the pub as well
indeed so i might well i can't be taking
advantage i've got to be here at seven
o'clock in the morning come monday
um but let's see of course 55 years at
55 years since your last appearance in a
major final
at just a year though uh since the
anniversary just a year though since you
launched your plan for jobs see what i
did there uh something you're
celebrating today as well i imagine
yeah i did yeah that that's right a year
ago today we launched
the plan for jobs and you know i'm
delighted that we stuck to that plan
and the plan is working i was out and
about all day yesterday
in the west midlands in wolverhampton
and every business i went to i could see
our plan in action
new kickstarters young people starting
their new jobs
doing so well apprentices learning new
skills
people who've been brought back from
furlough successfully and businesses
that now having got through the crisis
with our support
are looking to expand and grow the
unemployment numbers are
far lower than we feared a year ago when
i stood up and outlined the plan for
jobs so i am
absolutely delighted that it is working
and it doesn't end here
we've got support that continues
throughout the year and we want to drive
our recovery forward now and that's what
i know we can achieve
what we did have yesterday in the past
24 hours though was confirmation that
the 20 pounds uplifted to universal
credit is
is coming to an end it just explained
that decision because there are
a number of people including you know
colleagues within your own party in
duncan smith suggesting that it was a
way by which people could
could live with some dignity why remove
it and why remove it now
it was always meant to be a temporary
measure along with lots of other things
that we've done we've been dealing with
a
unprecedented crisis that required us to
do some extraordinary things but of
course
those things can't carry on forever
whether it's the furlough scheme
or other things so universal credit is
part of that overall package of support
but it's just one thing i think the
focus we have is trying to get as many
people as possible
into work and into well-paid work so
what you've seen the national living
wage has gone up this year that's worth
350 pounds for someone working
full time on the national living wage
and we're providing
huge number of opportunities for people
to get new skills
to upskill themselves to earn more and
to get better jobs
the prime minister's lifetime skills
guarantee ensures that everyone will
have
the chance to find a better future for
themselves and that's what we need to
focus on now that the economy is
reopening
businesses are booming and we want to
get people into work sure it is as you
say but
but a part of a package of assistance
for people but it is
a fairly fundamental and significant
part of it i mean during the liaison
committee
uh yesterday when the prime minister had
it pointed out to them if you go ahead
with this cut
unemployment support will be in real
terms at its lowest point for 30 years
that's not something any chancellor
should be proud of
well what i can say is support for
people finding
new jobs or better jobs or getting new
skills
is probably higher than it has ever been
so there are currently 10 million adults
in the uk who don't have a level three
qualification
for the first time the prime minister
outlined last year the government will
fully fund
those adults to get that qualification
that's worth three and a half thousand
pounds
roughly and if you get a qualification
like that your chance of getting a job
or earning more in a new job goes up
significantly
so that's just one example of the things
we're doing to help people we're giving
businesses
three thousand pounds to take on new
apprentices and paying 95
of the training costs for that
apprentices to create opportunities
for people there and i think that's the
right approach the best way
long term to help people is to help them
get into well-paid work
and we are throwing the kitchen sink at
that as part of our plan for jobs
and we did it early i said a year ago
today we outlined the plan it's
worked over the last year and it
continues to work and we should have
confidence
that it will help drive our recovery and
help provide people with the
opportunities they need
people understand that perhaps yes in
the long term that may well be the
priority and that may will be that
that may will lead to the best outcome
but in the short term people still have
to put food on the table
shoes on their children's feet and pay
their bills and as things stand
2.2 million people receiving universal
credit right now are in work they're not
off work 2.2 million
are currently in work is there not
something structurally significantly
wrong
with our labor market when you can have
in excess of 2 million people receiving
this form of benefit
while still turning up and having a job
well we've also done some other things
to improve the generosity of our welfare
system in other ways
and actually we put an extra billion
pounds a year into something called
local housing allowance
which helps those people who are
struggling with their rent bills so
you know over over a million people will
benefit from around 600
pounds a year from that and for those
that are in work as you say the best way
to help them is to make sure their wages
rise
that's why our increase of the national
living wage is important that's worth
350 quid for someone full time on the
national living wage
and that's why giving them the
opportunity to get new skills and then
earn more in the same job or a different
job is really important
and that's why the lifetime skills
guarantee as i said that's worth three
and a half thousand pounds when
someone gets one of those qualifications
or does an apprenticeship as part of
their work
to gain some new skills that is the
right long-term way
to help people and that's where we're
investing our money
some something we've discussed in some
depth with your colleague the business
secretary yesterday um
the the delay to the changing rules
around self-isolation
there has been something of a furious
backlash from the business community
well in fact even from your own party
ian duncan smith says he won't be going
to the pub
because there's no point in doing so
because you're going to get pinged
julian metcalf the founder of pret and
itsu
said that it is completely and utterly
mental richard walker
the boss of iceland said what an s
show
but i p i appreciate people's
frustration with this
it's part of a you know what i call a
prime minister called a balanced
approach
you know we want to make sure that we
proceed with the appropriate degree of
caution and i think
what people hopefully can look at is the
enormously positive news
of the restrictions being removed so
whether you're a hospitality business
you can see now that the one meter plus
rule is going it was one of the biggest
things that businesses talk to me about
the the restrictions on the number of
people coming together
to eat at a restaurant or go out has
also a bit will
also be removed when we move to this
step these are big changes that means we
have a huge degree of freedom back and i
appreciate people's frustration
but i'd also urge them to look at the
positives as well
but just in terms of test and trace in
terms of finding people who've come into
close contact with people who test
positive for covid19 and would be
required to self-isolate
we've gotten rid of the requirement or
we will get rid of on on july the 19th
the requirement for people to check into
venues the qr codes
we know i mean it's been reported
anecdotally and it's in the papers today
that people are deleting the nhs app
on mass how will we find people that
need to self-isolate
without the ability to track people
moving in and out of hospitality venues
if they're not using the nhs app
well i trust people to exercise
appropriate responsibility and judgment
and and i know that they they will
continue to do so as they have done over
the last year and a half
but i've spoken to health secretary
about this and he's aware of the
frustrations that people have around
this
and and what you know what i'd say is
that we have two different systems
for the test and trays we have obviously
the nhs one
and then we also have the app and i know
most people's concerns rest
with how the app is working and the
health sector is aware of that
that accounts for the majority of people
who need to isolate i understand on the
numbers and he's looking at
what the most appropriate balanced and
proportionate approach to isolation is
in these circumstances uh mr surak
well done again on last night best of
luck
for sunday and thanks very much for
talking to us this morning appreciate it
thanks very much take care